good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy thursday
congratulations on making it to the
latter half of the week you are amazing
i am amazing jackie's amazing bryce is
amazing strice is amazing thrice is
amazing the whole gang is here happy
thursday hey jax how you doing happy
thursday wow it's crazy how the tables
have turned and i used to how you turn
you
and now and you like actually really
didn't like it but then i capitalized on
it and made it a movement and it forced
you to like it once we're selling merch
i'm a capitalist at heart and when
something starts to yield revenue i will
be applying it to everyday life right
and now how you doing is the new downton
because now you're doing it more than me
jackie we need another list of things
that you like started that i stole the
white spanx pants i will have adorned
okay no
there's two lists one is things that
like you um just like maybe your own
what
we're against yes to no that's the
second thing the second thing is like
things you were so stubborn about and
like honestly made fun of me for and the
other thing is just like things that you
made your own that came from wah what's
that
white spanx pants you weren't against
them
no but i guess i was against the
culottes so they could be on the same
list okay things you were against
downton abbey reading
how you learn
oh and then wait once i was reading
kindle
oh right i like a real book
just the feel of the pages between my
fingertips and then something that you
started that i just like hopped on and
stole how you turn
even though that's still very much yours
no no that's not on the other list that
you were actually against how you doing
honestly i cannot keep up with my
inconsistencies honestly like that's why
we need the list that's why we need the
list and you guys drop a comment if you
can remember something that claudia was
initially against oh you were not into
me recapping succession
oh it wasn't no eyes were in the back of
your head i'm the worst if i was you i
would have quit like years ago i sound
miserable no and the succession one like
downton abbey i used to recap and it
took months for you to understand
succession it was like three days later
you were watching it and if only you
could have just been three days ahead we
could have been watching it together
okay well at least my turnaround time is
getting shorter that means i'm improving
it's true your turnaround time is
getting shorter turning around turning
around
turn around turn around
um
so i was all ready this week to like
kill it with my tv recaps and real
housewives of beverly hills wasn't even
on last night
so what's going on with garcelle's son
then
so
i
i know i'll tell you okay
actually like i haven't watched and i
was like claudia is going to explain it
i do think to that today's episode is
gonna be a lot of claudia explains it
all the stories are very you know
claudia's world
youthful they're very youthful there's
no stories about the titanic
unfortunately
but you know if any new news comes out
about the titanic you will hear it on
the morning toast first and that's a
promise
that i can guarantee
so with garcelle her son um had posted
on instagram that he was like just
getting harassed by these like [ __ ]
you know middle-aged bravo fans and he
was like leave me alone but what did he
do on the show when was he that has
nothing to do with the show oh just like
general harassment
like in what sort of way like positive
or negative we didn't see negatives okay
what is their beef with him
well like you know just cartel's like a
lightning rod and people are like taking
it out on her son if they're like siding
with diana you know
no it's a mental illness these people
who are imagine being that person
watching a tv show and then messaging
the son of someone you don't like that's
insane and we need to talk about toxic
bravo culture and toxic bravo fans
no it's been really bad for a long time
but i feel like definitely in the last
couple of years it's
reached a climax where people are so not
okay it's very um worrisome because
bravo fans are are grown ass adults this
isn't riverdale fans like they're
[ __ ] they're people with children
and they're acting like this on the
internet so garcelle had then posted
like leave my [ __ ] kids alone like
seriously i've had enough of you
um and then lisa rinna posted like leave
garcelle's kids alone and then bravo had
circulated this black and white graphics
that i guess that they made and it was
reminding me of when they fired stasi
like it was the same thing no it was so
serious and for bravo to speak out on
like fan
fodder which happens after every single
episode it has to have reached a level
that they had to respond which is insane
yeah and then there is um like a theory
going around and i haven't seen any
proof to either um
support or
unsupport this theory um but that the
people messaging uh garcelle's son were
like hired bots by diana
like it's being blamed on diana
which is so crazy if true but i haven't
seen literally any proof that there is
crazy if true so i don't want to put
that out there like as fact because i
don't know anything about it but that's
like what the peeps online are saying
okay honestly that would actually make
more sense than these grown ass people
no i see it bravo no no but they're
they're mentally ill and they're like
taken they're so taken with what goes on
on bravo and it's like
it's a tv show no it's so [ __ ] crazy
and i just like i love garcelle and any
pain in garcelle's home is a pain in my
home yeah that's so messed up i'm sure
like that's the worst thing and i saw i
had seen garcelle steam in where it's
like you know she could take whatever
like don't take it out on her kids and
it's like
you shouldn't even have to say that no
no it's so
it's so wrong
the bravo fans are are seriously not
okay they haven't been okay for a while
um if nothing else like i'm i'm i'm glad
that bravo is having obviously
garcelle's back and and
perhaps
we should be you know shedding light on
this issue because the bravo fans are
conversation and you know what you know
what needs to happen like we need to see
those messages and we need to find out
who those people are i'm not saying we
dox them and post their address but
if you're going to do something that
insane like stand by it i want to know
your name and we all should know your
name and perhaps what you do for a
living no but that's that's boxing no
but like it should be embarrassing for
them like just post a picture of them
and maybe their family you know
no that's stocks
that's literally what they're doing
i'm sure their family members don't know
that they're out harassing
minors because of something their mom
did on a tv show and maybe if they did
like it would embarrass those people to
a point where they realize that it's not
okay behavior
i mean i understand what you're saying
but too wrong she'll make her right girl
no of course not but if i was ever doing
something so crazy i obviously like
wouldn't tell you about it and then if
somebody told you like i would die right
that's a way to really it's like calling
their mom you know yeah
but no you're right i didn't realize
you're totally right that's stock sick
and not okay but still say their name
like i'm curious yeah i do like when
people like get a lot of hate from a
certain person and they just like post a
screenshot
my favorite thing in the world is when
people do that the anonymity like no why
am i gonna protect that but one of my
least favorite things is like when
people kind of like
not
they kind of like exaggerate the hate
that they get and they like one person
says something like remotely like not
supportive you know maybe a little
critical
on blast i agree with that like when i i
have blasted people but that's when
they're like actually like using the k
word nuts
and it's like there's multiple messages
where it's like this person is unwell
and it's time to expose that for years
they've been doing this yeah but there
is a line because sometimes people just
sort of like manufacture
all the hate that they get
and it's like they just didn't like your
outfit i mean it's right not bad like if
they're like i would never personally
bless someone who was like critique even
though that's exactly what i'm gonna do
today for a story that we have actually
let me pull up my screenshot i woke up
this morning and i chose to be petty oh
i love that for you anyways just like
most things there's a really fine line
where it's like you yes this is this is
good
until it's not
until it ain't maybe it was on the day
these things are so nuanced all these
discussions were happening this morning
this is like a scholarly academic
podcast it is because it's making me
question
where is that line
where is how many messages do you have
to get from someone with how many slurs
until you can expose them
oh also not to be like annoying secret
project girly but yesterday um
ben and josh recorded uh their second
podcast episode which comes out on
mondays josh peck and my husband ben
just launched a new podcast on tnn
called good guys and they had a guest
and like leave it to them on their
second episode to book like the most
premium a-list guest of all time i
joined like the interface that we use i
joined on the back end you can like join
backstage and just listen and not be
heard because i was like so wanting to
hear what this person was saying it
comes out on monday and i just want
everyone to know like get excited yeah
get excited
i know the secret
and i'm excited for all of you
i need like 45 seconds to find
what i need to find so if you want to
talk to everyone about like maybe tell
them what you're reading oh that's oh my
god thank you for
prompting me because i'm reading before
we were yours by lisa wingate as i
stated yesterday like i finally got into
it i would say up until 15
it was like it took me five days to even
get that far but now like i could not
put it down last night i'm at 50 i
stayed up way later than i should have
and i should have been getting some
sleep but i just like i need answers and
every other chapter goes back and forth
in time and i kind of hate that no but
no no it's it's really perfect because
the one that goes back in time is is the
better story but it's a lot to to digest
and so you need to break it up with the
one that goes forward in time but then
like i also needed answers but i
couldn't read another two chapters
before bed last night so hopefully i
will finish it today but i really
reading this book is like one i haven't
read a book this good in so long it's
reminding me of like when i read all the
great books you know where the crawdads
saying evelyn hugo etc and it's a book
that really needs to be read in a day or
two because i need answers i can't be
spreading this out and it's like it's
weighing on me like what's happening to
the fast children
yeah no i'm experiencing the same thing
but kind of like the polar opposite
because i'm loving this book so much
like i cannot read it because it'll be
over
that happens too but this is just
have you read love in other words by
christina lauren no
it's giving every summer after it's so
cute like i actually like almost like
cried last night like this moment was
just like so cute like this nerdy little
boy when he was 13 like it was so cute
um
loving it like obsessed oh great well
christina lauren they're writing duo and
they write so many of the book so many
books that like we would like and read
and you and snitch but for some like
very coho but for some reason like we
don't read as many of their books we
read one for the redheads was called
twice in a blue moon it was cute it was
good it was cute i like the beat but
people love christina lauren i feel like
after this you should go down to
christine
my way like because there's on my way
there's so many books and everybody
loves all of them
um i found the screenshot i was looking
for and it's evidentiary support for a
story we have about bethany and the
kardashians
okay can't wait
evidentiary support i love evident
cherry sport and i'm looking forward to
talking about that story because
oh my god i have so many thoughts talk
about nuance huh
talk about hypocrisy okay
okay we'll get into it we'll get into it
i think without further ado we should
get into it the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you uh
blessed bless my heart i've really made
it you know it's brought to you by
mcdonald's here at the morning toast
it's no secret that we are obsessed with
mcdonald's after a day of recording our
award-winning podcast or you know doing
anything else is there anything better
than a mcdonald's fountain diet coke a
large crispy french fry and their iconic
chicken sandwich and here's the
important question what is the best
mcdonald's crispy chicken sandwich the
standard the spicy the deluxe well it's
more personal than comedy for me it's a
standard uh no lettuce no nothing just
pickle i mean just ketchup but some
people might like extra pickles it's so
personal it's so customizable and they
have three different types of sandwiches
um it's really heaven whether you're
gonna get the spicy pepper sauce extra
crinkle cut pickles oh man i'm getting
so hungry thinking about this yeah me
too my mouth is watering for a bespoke
sandwich from a smoked sandwich and then
washing it down with a lay a large
bubbly crispy cold oh my god i'm so
hungry that diet coke sounds so good um
the mcdonald's crispy chicken sandwich
you can order it ahead on the mcdonald's
app try the sandwich that invented
crispy juicy tender today at
participating mcdonald's the app
downloaded registration is required um
and just like don't be dumb that's
really kind of the message today
mcdonald's don't be dumb mcdonald's
don't be dumb
stunning
today's episode is also brought to you
by kitsch they say that hair care is a
new skincare but there's one brand that
has taken it to the next level with a
cult-like following kitsch has created
game-changing essentials that beauty
enthusiasts swear by from satin
pillowcases to time-saving towels
kitch-nose hair care doesn't stop in the
shower i just have to say so i have a
ton of kitsch products like the satin
pillowcase um and i i love their
products but i when i was in florida at
your house i went to cvs to get like
just things to live and i bought a cloth
clip because i've been really into claw
clips but my hair is so
thick and so long oh how hard for you
and cbs had this huge monstrous one and
i bought it and i was like obsessed with
it and i ripped the tag off and it was
from kitsch
we'd love to see toe sponsors doing
fantastic things out in the world love
to see tow sponsors winning
so they have great clock lips they also
have shampoo and conditioner bars that
are bottle free beauty they work super
well it makes a lot of sense actually
and it's so much less waste they have
the heatless satin curling rollers no
more heat damage
and you can literally throw away like
your expensive curling irons um they
also have quick dry hair towels so i
hold a lot of moisture in my hair and i
like to have a specific towel
for drying my hair and the kitchen one
is really really good um and they're
classic hair ties and scrunchies which
are also just fabulous good elasticity
good stuff kitsch is offering you thirty
percent off your entire order at
mykitch.com toast that's right thirty
percent off anything and everything at
my kitch m y k i t s c
dot com slash toast that's my kitch dot
com slash toast for 30 off your order
thank you claudia okay now for the
stories
our first story vanessa bryant has been
awarded 16 million dollars after a jury
reached verdict in the trial over the
helicopter crash site photos
so vanessa bryant and her co-plaintiff
chris chester have been awarded a
combined 31 million dollars by an la
jury the final verdict was reached late
wednesday afternoon with the jury
finding that the los angeles county
sheriff's department and the fire
department did share photos of the
bodies of brian and chris's loved ones
and in doing so invaded their privacy
and caused emotional distress the jury
ordered the lasd to papen us to ten
million dollars and to pay chris a total
of nine million dollars while the lafd
is ordered to pay the pair six million
dollars each
good literally good yeah
um i feel like we knew the outcome of
this
case before it even started like it was
a clear violation of whatever policy
obviously a violation of ethics but also
a violation of police policy
so we knew that she was gonna win um
and i'm happy for her obviously like in
a situation like this you know money
really doesn't
mean much
when so when you've lost so much um
so yeah there's that but it feels good
to have like justice be served yeah and
i think it's you know sets a good
precedent
and
perhaps we'll stop this from happening
unfortunately to the next person no we
needed to set a precedent for this oh i
know so absurd and i also didn't realize
until i was reading recently like
the
what's the word like the gory nature of
the photos
the way that they died it had to have
been extremely graphic i didn't realize
that yeah like
i can only imagine it's so [ __ ] up
it's so like defies common decency let
alone police policy and law
um and the fact that anyone would do
this is so [ __ ] moronic honestly
um
and this and it just like made the whole
grieving process i'm sure
that much more difficult yeah because
what he passed away two years ago and
they've been on this lawsuit ever since
so while trying to grieve and move on
with your life you have to go back to
meetings with your lawyer and all this
stuff and relive it yeah and go to it's
hard and be on trial it's horrible i'm
glad it's like emotional abuse it's
concluded and that the jury found favor
with the victims same and just like
always wishing vanessa bryant like
endless peace
endless peace
just
oh
literally terrible yeah
agreed
okay our next story a little
sinking ship news sylvester stallone's
wife jennifer flavin filed for divorce
after 25 years yesterday add him to the
list add him to the list so sylvester
stallone's wife has filed for divorce
page six can confirm the former model
file paperwork to dissolve her 25-year
marriage to rocky in palm beach county
florida on august 19th court documents
obtained by page six state the marriage
is irretrievably broken and note that
jennifer is requesting assets
accumulated during the union to be
equitably distributed between them
also so there's a few other factoids
about orton you know alleged factuates
about this story because a few days ago
it was shown that he was getting a
tattoo on his arm that was like covering
up his wife's face with a tattoo of a
dog
and then also yesterday it's just mean
also yesterday there were reports that
they were divorcing over this dog rocky
has since said that was untrue but they
did have um
disagreements in how to like uh
raise the dog or whatever um
this is how you know famous people like
don't have real problems no but also
sometimes it's like you're having so
many issues with someone and it's like
whatever the last straw is i actually
think it might have been the dog so he's
denying claims that his marriage ended
because of his dog on wednesday it was
reported that she filed for divorce
because they fought over a new
rottweiler named dwight the argument
over the dog jennifer didn't want
another pet while
uh sylvester wanted the dog for
protection supposedly led to an
extremely heated argument that brought
up other issues but he told tmz quote we
did not end the relationship on such a
trivial argument although he did concern
that the couple disagreed over how to
care for the dog given that they often
travel and live in two homes
what
i so i actually do think not that the
dog is what broke them up but like
that's a part of it that was the last
disagreement they could handle
that is like funny
um and it also makes me think like you
know thank god adele
bought the house from rocky because that
would have been another asset that they
would have to go back and forth on who
gets but now they just split the money
dell bought the house from rocky i
didn't know where you were going with
think gotta tell
yeah well now like adele's 60 million
dollars in mortgage and down payment is
going to be split 50 50
between
jennifer and rocky wow i love when
things circle back to previous toast
news 100
so that's crazy i mean 25 years in
hollywood
is as it's a success it's as successful
as it gets especially for someone like
rocky you know right because
he's up there what about rocky and khloe
kardashian oh let me get the list out
what about
i got it rocky and sherry ray
obsessed
obsessed
hold on let me get the list yeah because
we need more age-appropriate people on
that list like we're obviously covering
a lot of young hollywood i've broken out
the list by hc sherry ray sherry ray was
down here on her own
right rocky
and perhaps jennifer and shaq
who's jennifer ex-wife
yeah what does she do she's like a model
what is she
supermodel
former supermodel how nice for her yeah
well um
rocky i am not available but if you want
to give me half i can get divorce mario
get divorced and then get married again
do you have you ever seen rocky
the movie
oh why do i keep calling him rocky i
literally
it it literally did not compute for me
because i kept almost saying the rock oh
my god i never realized there's a
celebrity named the rock and a celebrity
named rocky but that was just his name
in the movie right yeah yeah but it's
like sylvester
his name is stilvester but i think he
goes by rocky too at this point no i
think he goes by sly yeah but i everyone
calls him rocky you know all of a sudden
i just had like a
like a brain awakening like yeah like oh
my wait your name is not rocky no i've
never seen any of those movies
no meaning
no
i feel like we're going to get so much
crap
really i don't think so like sorry we're
so young
that that movie was just like before our
time like we were we're like literally
teaming like babies also we're just so
tiny we're so feminine that like and
like what's boxing
oh
is that like like a sport like football
we're so feminine we're the most
feminine so feminine
are you ready for our next story that
you're gonna have to explain to me
yes
tick tock star gabby hannah the cops
were called for her welfare welfare
check after a string of bizarre posts
don't even read it i'll tell you oh okay
this was all happening like a live on
tick tock over the last couple of days
like yesterday
first
who's gabby hannah
great question thank you um she is like
one of like i think older generation
youtuber like
i think um
i've personally never engaged with her
content i only know
her like from her um scandals
but she was like friendly with trisha
paytas like she's in that og crew but
she kind of had like a renaissance on
tik tok she has like seven million
followers on tick tock um but mostly
because people just like drag her
endlessly like they make fun of
everything she does her music her
content her art like she gets trolled
professionally for real
um and she's
been vocal about
struggling with mental health
so that's the the background
okay i'm listening yesterday
and the day before
she had posted
hundreds of tick tocks like hundreds
um in her house and it's very clear that
she's having some sort of manic episode
she's going on and on about how she
solved the puzzle and jesus and there's
blood on the carpet and like just very
clearly someone going through like some
sort of psychosis like a mental
breakdown
um
and it's all happening in real time
and people are commenting like oh my god
you know where are your friends and
family someone needs to call the police
like she's not okay she needs help
um
and it escalated when a fan of hers
who lives nearby and knows where she
lives decided to go over to her house
while she's in the middle of this manic
episode
and she's like live streaming the whole
thing so he's making tick tocks that
he's going to go over there
and he goes over there and gabby's tick
tocks start including this man
and this man had told her that he didn't
know who she was but like wanted to hang
out and she's in the throes of this
manic episode so she's like great so
they're running around the house
drinking water like laughing giggling
making videos and he's like lurking in
the background of all these videos
looking like such a [ __ ]
freak scary stalker man
and all the comments are like gabby get
this man out of your house he's like
just walking behind her and all these
videos looking so
creepy
and everyone was like i do not have a
good feeling about this i do not have a
good feeling about this
then
sh the last video she posted with him
she's screaming at him she's like you
lied to me you know who i am get the
[ __ ] out of my house
and he picks up like a bottle of pills
and it's like gabby please take these
pills
and she's like that's for my
it was like something like innocuous
like my tmj or something like
she's like those are pills for my
like headaches or whatever get the [ __ ]
out of my [ __ ] house you [ __ ]
c-u-n-t she said that word she's
screaming at him and then the video ends
because these are only like 10 second
tick tocks um
then i guess he leaves because this guy
is now clout chasing around town live
streaming last night i checked hit 30
000 tick tock followers he was making
videos answering people people are like
you literally took advantage of a
vulnerable person you're a freak and you
did nothing to help like you know where
she lives call the police call for help
call her like do something and he's like
fighting for his life on tick tock like
thinking he was gonna you know become a
star and now he's just the [ __ ] freak
who took advantage of someone who
clearly is struggling with mental
illness
soon gabby goes on she's figured out you
know
the
the bushes in her yard that grow berries
are the key to the puzzle like it's very
you know sort of manic behavior the
final video she has posted and has not
posted since last night was her she's
holding the camera into her mirror so
you see her she's literally whispering
like there's someone in my house please
pray for me like she was crying
and then we haven't heard from her again
then this report that tmz just uh
released was that the police were called
to her house and that's probably why we
haven't heard from her
now there's a lot of conversation online
about whether this is staged
which is so [ __ ] up like for people to
think and so [ __ ] up if it is because
she's kind of known for like troll
behavior but i mean
you know
viola davis couldn't act it so well it
was so real gabby had is not an actress
it was so
obvious that that was not staged and the
element of the fan was just so [ __ ]
weird yeah um and now people are really
worried about her because we haven't
heard
what's going on and we're obviously not
gonna hear from her if the police were
called her house she's probably
hopefully getting treatment yeah so lapd
sources told tmz that the videos led to
an influx of calls from people worried
about her well-being
and asking for officers to go and check
on her tmz is told that gabby greeted
officers at her door and chatted for a
few minutes before officers called for a
psycho psychological evaluation team
medical professionals had a long chat
with gabby and determined she didn't
pose a threat to herself or anyone else
so they allowed her to remain in her
home they're told gabby was also given
resources for the next time she may
become upset
oh so
she's at her house she yeah they didn't
seem to find it an issue
like a grave issue right
well i don't know what her relationship
is with like family or friends but she
needs like support yeah does she i mean
i'm sure she has friends or family
hopefully that aren't you know in the
famous but does she have influencer
friends that she's like actually close
with do you know
like no i think what she really at least
what i know her for was her friendship
with trisha paytas that then ended like
very dramatically and very publicly oh
how did that happen there
i don't know like they just
it was a lot i think a part of it had to
do with the frenemies podcast it always
comes back to the frenemies podcast the
frenemies podcast was a cultural shift
really
it really was at least a digital culture
shift oh yeah
the frenemies podcast but do they still
do frenemies
no remember they broke right but i
didn't know if ethan question mark was
doing frenemies but by himself
so ethan had his own podcast before
called h3 that i know um and it's like a
tnn they have a lot of different shows
and frenemies was one of them frenemies
doesn't exist anymore but he has tons of
other shows okay yeah cause i see h3 a
lot yeah in the podcast store i think
they're they they're shark toppers
they're chart toppers for sure
so um that's really my my extent of
gabby hannah my extent of knowledge
before this situation of gabby hannah is
very limited i had just heard of her and
honestly like what
what the internet makes you think of her
is like she's crazy like a couple maybe
like a year ago this um audio went viral
on tick tock and it turned out that it
was from her she was on a podcast
um where she's it was honestly like so
something i would do she's like talking
and then immediately goes into song it's
one of her songs and what like the
message she was trying to convey through
like the point she was making on the
podcast was like the exact message she
had once written in one of her songs so
she just started singing the lyrics um
and i felt that
yeah i feel that overall though this
story is extremely disturbing so sad as
a lay person
just hearing like i didn't having not
having watched the videos not knowing
her not knowing whether this is
real or stage i think it's real
i think it is too i mean
i know people do like crazy [ __ ] on the
internet for attention
but i just i can't i refuse to believe
that
this is fraudulent
okay well hopefully she's okay
hopefully she's okay um
and hopefully she's like good people
around her yeah
but if you watch the videos like they're
chilling you know and i think people who
have either had episodes like that
themselves or
close people to them in their life who
have had episodes like that like it was
very um
it was real like the stuff that she was
saying is exactly how
one slips into an episode like that you
know figuring out the puzzles is like a
very common theme when you're going
through psychosis like you know thinking
their people after you and i don't even
think
there really probably was someone in her
house but that's what you think of yeah
when you're going through that like
paranoia yeah
so i think it was totally real and it's
very sad
very sad okay well hopefully hopefully
she's doing okay and and we'll get we'll
find out more an update but hopefully
she takes like some time honestly if we
don't hear from her for a while i think
that would be good like i think the
internet and the amount of hate that she
incessantly guessed i i think it had a
lot to do with what probably led her to
this point
yeah
okay well are you ready for our next
story
if it's a story that's brought to you by
a clinique
yes
if you have dark spots it can often feel
like a vicious cycle as soon as one
fades another one pops up break the
cycle with the clinique even better
clinical dark spot interrupter this
powerful serum works on melanin rich to
fair skin and it helps physically
correct dark spots such as acne acne
scars while protecting from
discoloration so i get really bad dark
spots especially in the sun and it's so
annoying because they're very difficult
to get rid of and then once you do like
there's one right next to it like a new
neighbor pops up comes to its funeral
it's so annoying um and i really trust
clinique as a brand and their even
better clinical dark spot interrupter
is proven to work so at 94 percent of
people demonstrated an improvement in
radiance and visible skin tone including
acne marks in just eight weeks you can
see a 39 visible reduction in dark spots
in 12 weeks
also their damage eraser brightening
complex is more concentrated with
boosted technology to deliver dramatic
brightening results but it's gentle
enough for all skin types so they have
really like a wide range of products
that are really good for your skin i
feel like clinique is a brand that's
been around for a long time it's totally
a brand that you can trust and their
products are meant to help all types of
skin tones complexions so that's melon
and rich skin to fair skin
they'll visibly improve uneven skin tone
interrupt the look of future dark spots
um and that's the even better clinical
serum foundation
from
clinique and the even better clinical
dark spot interrupter so you use the
interrupter in your skincare and then
the foundation is like i hate when your
skin is like doing well and then you
have to put on a lot of makeup and it's
just
undoing all of the work that you just
did but the clinique foundation is
fabulous first of all their coverage is
like so glowy it's really nice but it
also it has skin care inside of it so
it's not going to undo all the work that
you've been doing at night you know
taking care of your skin
so you can get the even better clinical
dark spot interrupter today it's
available at clinique.com clinique is
c-l-i-n-i-q-u-e-dot-com
great thank you
our next story bethany frankel is
alleging that tick-tock has shadow
banned her after slamming the
kardashians
victim mentality okay that bethany
franco claims she's been shadow banned
on tick tock following comments about
the kardashians and celebrity brands the
real housewives of new york city alum
spoke out against the reality tv family
on just b with bethany frankel she said
quote we need a kardashian intermission
admitting she was not sure if she should
continue commenting on the family she
said quote and i've honestly been afraid
to say it it's not because chris is the
mafia and controls a lot of the media
because i don't give a [ __ ] cancel me
she said what are we saying to our kids
what is the message take it all be as
rich as possible filter as much as
possible be as fake as much as possible
brag as much as possible i feel like i'm
sounding like her when i'm reading this
yeah
get plastic surgery and lie about it as
much as possible what the [ __ ] are we
doing then do a charity donation to like
rinse it over as much as possible
what are we never once done that by the
way
yeah just donate it to a charity when
someone gives them critique then after
this rant which i ran like did go
semi-viral i saw it on reels um
it got a lot of seem positive people
agreeing with her obviously people
disagreeing with her it's
it's not necessarily a hot take to come
for the kardashians but i hate when
she's like i've been wanting to say this
no but i didn't i did find that what
she's saying about them
is is newish because a lot of times it's
not like obviously completely a new idea
but like people come for them for a lot
of different reasons but this idea that
what example do we set for our kids by
being obsessed with them like just to
take as much as possible and to get a
plastic surgery and to lie about it like
the it
okay i want to say it wasn't your
typical like they're stupid yeah okay i
want to say something let's talk about
what she said first then we'll talk
about everything that happened okay i
had such a problem with her take on the
kardashians let me tell you why the
first thing is her whole message was
like you know what are we teaching our
children and it's like we
aren't teaching your child anything
she's your child like your teaching
brain i hate that thing like well
they're not a good role model what are
we teaching our children like what are
you you are responsible for what you
teach your children not [ __ ] me and
i'm not gonna act a certain way so that
some random person's child can learn
something do you know what i mean
yeah it's not our it's not the
kardashian's responsibility to take care
of brynn hoppy right but i also think
i think so many things about this on the
i just went sorry my point i'm obsessed
with the kardashians but hearing like
her opinion about this like it doesn't
really bother me i don't really agree
with her but i actually do can i can see
where she's coming from i can't
if you're gonna critique the kardashians
for everything they could be teaching
young people you then have to be a
perfect person who's never taught a
young person anything poor and one could
argue
benny bethany's contribution to toxic
diet culture with her 200 million dollar
brand called skinny girl glorifying
being thin you know she's not a perfect
person either and what does that teach
my child bethany that in order to be
cool i have to be skinny
i think that i don't know i know bethany
controls the media and she's the mafia
but i'm gonna say that don't cancel me
okay don't cancel her i'm sorry if
you're gonna be a public person out here
critiquing other perfect people lily
reinhardt you then have to be a perfect
person who's never ever whose image
isn't completely untainted and you know
what lily reinhardt's image is pretty
untainted so she might have more of a
leg to stand on than bethany like i
think we can all and i love bethany
especially on housewives but i can hand
you a laundry list of things that she
has done
that are not perfect and that her image
could potentially be teaching young
people poor things
yeah
sorry
i guess i just think that
she's not wrong in some of the stuff
that she's saying but i also think like
they do set a good example in a lot of
other ways like take as much as you want
they're the they're the most wealthy
first of all i think our obsession with
the kardashians as a society says more
about us than it does about them like if
they were so terrible then we wouldn't
be so obsessed but i also think in a lot
of ways they set a really great example
like the fact that they are so
successful like couldn't be bigger
couldn't be more rich
family-oriented yet there's still this
rock solid family like i think that
their emphasis on family is one of the
best messages that we can be sending to
young children it's like no matter what
you do no matter where you go like it
always comes back to your family like i
think family is the bedrock
of like
uh of them of and also just like at
least for me like a a happy fulfilled
fulfilling life yes and that's not the
case for everyone no it's not the case
for everyone but i think putting the
fact that they put such an emphasis on
family is a huge check in their column
and so she wants to only talk about the
negatives but yeah no i'm not gonna lie
that the fact that they get plastic
surgery and then like lie about it and
not tell us about it like that is that's
not a great example because i think
everyone should get plastic surgery if
they want it but like just like this
whole thing of like
it doesn't bother me i can't explain it
like
yes they're public figures but if
somebody wants to go do something with
their body they literally don't owe us
anything like they don't always an
explanation and if they want to lie
honestly and this goes for anyone like
if you want to lie like okay i would
probably lie to like if i needed a nose
job i would totally get one and if i was
like embarrassed of it even though i
wouldn't because i would like
love to like exploit myself online and i
didn't want to share like i would
[ __ ] lie about it i would like
some things can be [ __ ] personal even
if you're a completely public person
i don't agree with this like in order to
be a good celebrity you have to tell us
everything you've ever done to your body
like [ __ ] off no i don't think it's
everything you've ever done to your body
but like it's really
up until when when kim did that recent
interview we still thought she was
allergic to botox yet she looks younger
than i knew she wasn't i
know but it's like i hear
like
i don't know i just think like you don't
know why things everything with them has
to make sense do you know what i mean
like yeah nobody's holding everyone and
there's so many other there's so many
other stuff because people don't care
about those other people because people
deeper like because people deeply deeply
care about the kardashians because
we love them
because they're awesome it's just like
this
this obsession with making sure
everything the kardashians do in their
lives launching their lives launching
their business has to be 100 consistent
with everything they've ever done and
everything they've ever said is first of
all no way to live first of all
normalize changing your mind and second
of all like we literally don't even do
that to anyone else i agree with that
the obsession with like calling them out
like gotcha
is so [ __ ] annoying and i don't
subscribe to that at all
and this obsession with other
celebrities doing it to them
bethany lily reinhardt like that bothers
me like why is nobody calling out like
the biggest
man yeah i could give me five minutes
i'll find a big-ass inconsistency
because nobody cares someone because
nobody cares about them
really it's so annoying it really
bothers me and that's why yes i'm a
kardashian apologist but a lot of the
time like i don't want to even entertain
what someone has to say about the
kardashians even if it's legitimate
because it's not coming from a good
place oh and this was my evidentiary
support ready heavy is the head that
where's the crown claude
so two days ago or yesterday on the
toast we were talking about how andrew
garfield is doing like a six-month fast
or whatever to lose all this weight get
in shape for a role and there's not even
a semblance of backlash but kim did the
same thing of she's not an actress but a
role she played was marilyn at the met
gala she did something similar um and
got roasted and so like where's the
backlash on andrew garfield yeah
so this person
wrote this comment and it's a public
platform so i i mean it's on youtube
like it's public i'm gonna say his name
okay you're gonna say the person who uh
commented on our video
yeah
no okay maybe i won't i mean people are
gonna find it
andrew garfield fasted on and off for
six months
kim k did a crash diet for six weeks to
fit her nasty fat ass in the dress she
ripped anyway not the same thing so this
is a person who thinks that kim is
contributing to toxic diet culture but
he's going around on the internet
calling women nasty and fat
see that's what i'm saying might this
have been a legitimate critique yes you
you obviously aren't coming from a good
place you don't care about diet culture
you're calling a random woman you've
never met fat
i don't even think that's a good
critique because he fasted on and off no
but i'm saying like if
if he wanted to have like an actual
argument and make a point like i could
see but
that's the thing
so when andrew garfield fasts on and off
it's fasting when kim goes on a diet
it's a crash diet how come andrew
garfield's not no his point which might
have been legitimate was that it's six
weeks for six months like what makes
kim's version of it toxic is that it was
so fast and who was he diet who was he
who was who who is this guy to say that
because at six weeks it's too soon and
it's six months it's good no but what
i'm saying is like the irony of this
post like yeah yeah
kim
and her
her toxic diet culture and setting an
unrealistic beauty standard when you're
literally calling her a nasty a nasty
fat ass
yeah no i get what you're saying the
critique of the kardashians to me
whether it's legitimate ever no never
comes it's like an honest or true place
it's just i need to see your critique of
dozens of other celebrities
and then you know if the kardashians are
mobs and that sure because they are
amongst the biggest but i need to see
your critique of everyone first not just
them
so it just bothers me like even when
people make legitimate points i just
don't think they're coming from an
honest or real or authentic place
so with bethany while i don't even agree
with what she said like i hate that
whole thing of like
why is it everyone else's responsibility
to teach your child things you know like
we're all responsible for our own
dependence you know yeah and there are
so many there's so many celebrities out
there so many role models like if you
don't like how what these people are
showing your kids then pivot there's
other people who might be saying exactly
what you want to hear the world is a big
place and one of the consequences of
living in this world is growing up going
outside and seeing things that either
offend you that either contradict what
you believe that are different
so this expectation that every celebrity
should be the values that you want to
teach your child is so [ __ ] stupid
and it's not their responsibility it's
just not like it's not
so i didn't like what she said but i
empower women to say what they want
especially on podcasts yeah then what i
really i always like a hot take so it
didn't bother me even though i you know
how i disagree and how i love them how
they are what i think i think they're
great role models
oh my god can't shove my children in
front of the television fast enough
kardashians okay totally my children
aspire to that house aspire to that
plane my children will be breastfed from
the milk of kim kardashian okay i'll
figure out a way she should battle it
and sell it you'll give it to your kids
100
yeah
but then what really started to bother
me i wasn't bothered about this story i
was just like whatever was bethany's
like victim mentality content coming out
afterwards like
you know
i believe that if you have something to
say and it's not unpopular like you
should say it and no matter like the
risk like you should say it and i
actually agree with that like if you
really feel a certain way and people are
just because it's popular doesn't mean
it's right and just because it's right
doesn't mean it's popular i agree often
it's quite the opposite
but then she like went on this like
victim
rant about how like she's being silenced
and you know people are not going to
want to associate with her and i was
like first of all not that many people
listen to your podcast so just calm down
and second of all like what are you
talking about okay so you think you're
the first person to ever critique the
kardashians do she
thinks she's been shadow band because of
this rant her views if you look at her
tick tock like i do think she's been
shadow banned but i don't know what it's
from let me look let me look because i
know that bethany um is popular on tick
tock for her makeup reviews
yeah she's like be real you know
i'm not gonna tell you what's good
because it's expensive i'm not being
paid to this [ __ ] from the drugstore
rocks this trash from armani sucks like
that's why people really like her and
that's how she's grown a following and
it's been really smart and i keep
waiting she's gonna announce skinny girl
cosmetics like any minute now
so
i mean her views seem like pretty good
they've see that's the thing with
tick-tock like you're always one video
is a million and the other is 50 000.
unless you're like addison ray
with like a crazy fan base there's so
much inconsistency some of like you the
biggest tick tockers you go and watch
there's like a difference of millions
yeah i want to just look at it no it's
definitely gone down a little bit
what's a little bit
like
i don't know views are so inconsistent i
would say before she's averaging about
like a
like 250 k
and her last couple videos are like 100
between 100 and 150. maybe the content
just sucks like
so you don't think she's shadow
well the thing is i always think i'm
shadow band on tick tock um that's and
i'm pretty sure i am like i'm 100 sure
but um what i have to realize sometimes
is like just nobody cares and my
content's not good like
it could be that
okay
what do you think kris jenner no no
that's not what i think tick tock i
think she's probably shadow band for an
unrelated reason and she just thinks
it's because of this extremely hot take
and i just like hate i i always hate
that like
kardashians control the media so like
you can't speak out that's not how it is
at all not at all i mean everybody talks
crap about them and no offense like do
you think the kardashians like really
care what bethany said so much so that
they're going to have her silenced no
not what not at all
so like this the thing that bothered me
the rant didn't even bother me i just
disagreed with it the aftermath of her
being like such a victim
really was like oh my god calm down
yeah like the way she was talking on her
instagram story about how she needs to
be brave and say things that people are
afraid to say she was acting like edward
snowden like
it was so or is that the one who like
did treason yeah yeah like he had to do
it
yeah calm down
yeah i agree with that it was given
julian assange you know yeah and she's
really not saying anything like that
crazy to criticize the kardashians like
is
you know the oldest story in the book
yeah like
calm down
yeah but she did it with extra fervor
and because she's bethany and she is a
really great debater like she gave she
came out
full force you know oh and it's worth
mentioning that some of the content
about the kardashians that goes viral
most on tick tock is negative
calling out the stormy photoshop all
that [ __ ] starts
on tick tock so i have a hard time
believing that that's why got it okay
well
nice spirited debate
we'd love that
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
only if it's the story that's brought to
you by a company that is saving brands
left right and center including the
morning toast
do you have any idea what it is
see
yeah i do
key
um
honestly as always with these ads i
don't really feel the need to explain to
you like why you're dumb for not being
on canva pro
nevertheless i will
creating visual content is essential
part of what we do if you follow us on
instagram or on youtube we always need
graphics thumbnails social assets and
neither jackie nor i are like truly
trained graphic designers and ben
introduced me to canva
years ago now i'm a happy canva pro
subscriber and customer
it's super easy to collaborate with your
design team anyone else on your team
when you use canva for teams it makes
the whole process so much more creative
and fun so canva for teams is a design
platform that makes it easy for anyone
to create stunning content in any format
from social media presentations websites
the endless templates and premium fonts
photos graphics and videos add
personality and edge to our team's
content with features designed for brand
consistency canva for teams make it easy
to maintain your aesthetic and add your
logos fonts and brand colors to anything
you create canva for teams streamlines
how we do social media we can plan
create and share social media content
directly to all of our channels in one
place and you can even schedule posts
ahead of time they have a video editor
that is so easy to use with tons of
filters animations and transitions that
will bring your group's content to life
so whatever kind of business you run i
think it's really important that you
have like really engaging fun and
consistent content on your social media
um and canva is great for that no one's
gonna know that you're an amateur it
looks so
experienced and it really is great for
keeping your brand colors your brand
logos your brand vibe in mind and it
doesn't look chaotic
you can collaborate with canva for teams
right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial when you go to canva dot
me slash toast that's c-a-n-v-a dot m-e
slash toast for a free 45-day extended
trial canva.me slash toast great thank
you claudia
you're welcome
fifth and final story barbie ferreira is
leaving euphoria after rumored sam
levinson feud barbie really quick
i sent you the story and i guess didn't
make the cut that's totally fine um but
olivia rodrigo was brought out of billy
joel last night it didn't make the cut
oh my god that's so funny because i'm
obsessed with it like i bet that she
knows billy joel cause you played her
uptown girl like billy joel being
relevant everything to me like in the
world this man deserves the world
um
they sang deja vu there's videos of it
online and then she performed uptown
girl with him and it was just like
iconic and i didn't see like a pop
culture
relevant moment
for billy joel this year like i just
didn't see that yeah
and i guess we don't need to talk about
it because um you're usually right about
these things but i just wanted to
mention that it was up as a contender
and i just wanted to say like i was so
here for it oh i'm so glad that that it
sparked joy for you yeah
continue sorry barbie ferreira announced
on wednesday that she will not be
returning for season three of euphoria
to play the iconic cat hernandez she
posted on her instagram story after four
years of getting to embody the most
special and enigmatic character cat i'm
having to say a very teary-eyed goodbye
i hope many of you could see yourself in
her like i did and then she brought you
joy to see her journey into the
character she is today i put all my care
and love into her and i hope you guys
could feel it love you catherine
hernandez so fans were very upset to
hear this news um
though
apparently last year it came out that
she was reportedly cuts from part of the
show after rumor swirled that she and
the creator of the show sam levinson got
into a heated argument during production
and that she walked off set at least
twice so it's like shocking but not
because she was such a prominent
character in season one and then season
two like you would have thought her
character died like she was never
[ __ ] around and then it came out that
like she was beefing with sam
um and i don't know what the beef is but
i'm inclined to take barbie's side just
because sam there's been like a lot of
weird
things said about sam and the fact that
like
there's a lot of weird sexual things
with the show like
i don't know i'm just inclined to take
barbie's side and i actually think it's
really cool and like um
i have a lot of respect for the fact
that like she's not just like staying
quiet just to stay on this huge show
like she's standing up for her
principles and like her values and even
if that means losing a role on the
biggest show right now
she's doing that and i i think that's
admirable because it could never be me
like i would say sure sam sure yeah like
just to stay relevant and i think it's
really um it's admirable yeah that's
true i'm so curious what
the beef is
i just think and this is totally
unsubstantiated i think like sam is like
creepy
and like weird
um
yeah
like if you watch the show like the
obsession with having as much and
they're not underage but their
characters are so the obsession with
having so much underage nudity is
[ __ ] weird yeah
i mean i don't i don't watch it
appropriate i can that wouldn't do it
for me it's it's inappropriate like it
is and it's not because they're all like
in their 20s but still they're in high
school what does it say about the
culture that everyone's obsessed with it
and it's the biggest show yeah no for
sure
twisting and i think the show is really
good in some ways of like
you know
i do think it's hella accurate in some
ways of what it's like to be a teenager
right now
um but i also think it's really not
accurate in a lot of ways too and it's
very like fantastical which is what
makes it a good show
um
and i think this is a loss for the show
like cats season one like she was like a
webcam girly like it was so
[ __ ] funny um and she was great and i
think it was huge you know i think
technically barbie started as an
influencer so we love to see influencers
and digital personalities out here
thriving at the mac gala on a big hbo
show um
but i do have a lot of respect for this
i really do
yeah me too
and i think the show will not suffer to
a point where it'll like you know
end it but i do think you know we'll be
missing on some cat drama well perhaps
this leaves you know for a transfer
student to come in to euphoria high
school maybe a plus-sized jewish girl
what high school do they go to not
euphoria high
no they don't go to euphoria high school
what is the name of the high school like
they're never in school they're always
just like doing drugs outside at the
park i don't know the name of the high
school but i think it's probably
euphoria high school and i don't watch
euphoria just whenever we know
there might be some new listeners here
it's been a while since you recapped it
and um i know you're right you're right
that's why it's a claudia explains at
all moment for sure even though like you
saying what's the name of the high
school euphoria high school i think
pretty much everyone knows that you
don't watch
i don't know i don't know where the show
takes place
euphoria tennessee
euphoria though
euphoria
is it called euphoria because they're
always on drugs you know reaching
euphoria
i think so well is it because like teens
you know high school is the best time
for it time in your life
drugs plays a really big role in the
show from like most of the characters
experimenting with drugs but mostly
following rue's enormous struggle with
addiction and chasing that euphoric high
and maybe like because of the sex
no are they having euphoric sex
no unless unless it's with nate
jacob
um
no the euphoria title has nothing to do
with the sex i think it has to do with
drugs
are they eating euphoric food
no
i've actually never seen anyone eat on
the show
they're too busy like [ __ ] and doing
drugs
okay or go to school like they never go
to school why do you think it's called
euphoria sound off in the comments
sound off in the comments we need a
sound off in the comments button boom
sound off in the comments we need a lot
of buttons i'll make a list
funny
um okay so that's our show i'm headed to
new jersey right now i have a show in
red bank new jersey tonight
so if you're in the area i can't wait to
see you and if you haven't gotten a
ticket there are a few left in the back
are there opening up in the front i
don't know tickets tickets tickets no
it's actually pretty much like close to
sold out so it's like tickets
there's tickets
okay well you guys you should go if
you're around new jersey we love the new
jersey toasters we are at one point the
biggest podcast in new jersey maybe not
anymore since we keep insulting them
about creme de la creme yeah that means
cream
but also um for my pacific northwest
gurlies in a few weeks i am headed to
portland in seattle for shows and i
would love to see you there so that's
girl with no job.com tour
and anything you want to plug
the redheads the best podcast in the
world number one show on earth i'm
sitting right here
you're on it sometimes oh wait yes wait
tomorrow there's no episode we are
taking a summer friday we told everyone
that but i might have a little something
up my sleeve
so just look out tomorrow there's no
standard episode yeah i'm i'm
jackie's off but that's not why there's
no episode not because no no we took a
summer friday it's not because of me
no it's not because of you um but i
might i might sprinkle a little
something into your into your inboxes
with a with a gap into your rss feed
yeah i'm just saying don't count out the
counters
um so yes and then we're back monday for
another fabulous week of remote shows so
thank you to everyone who's been so
supportive we love you so much and thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the first five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcasting
where podcasts can be outside spotify
itunes central public radio air radio
catbacks all over the places wavelengths
and bodyguards find us the morning
chosen leave a five-star view about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an enclave amazing day and
we'll see you together on monday bye see
you on monday
bye oh bruno's up
i may love you